PBS News senior national security
contributor and former acting and deputy
CIA director Michael Morell joins us
Michael happy new year thanks for being
here you heard he and Lee and his
rapport pose the question is this the
beginning of the end of US military
presence in Iraq how bad is this
situation so the attack on the embassy
was bad but now this has moved to the
Iraqi parliament where it could be even
worse worse how because there's going to
be a debate in the Iraqi parliament
about whether the US military should go
home or not that was the deal to get the
protesters to withdraw so it's possible
that the Iraqi parliament could vote in
favor of the u.s. leaving which would
put intense pressure on us why does that
matter it matters because we are still
fighting Isis in Iraq and it would be
akin to the u.s. pulling out in 2011
which gave al-qaeda in Iraq which
ultimately became Isis a big boost so we
could see that whole thing play out
again well at present far from leaving
more US troops are actually entering the
region so as we see this cycle of
violence between the u.s. and Iranian
backed of factions where could this take
us what's next so so it could take us
one place right which is the withdrawal
from Iraq which we'd be bad the other
place that could take us is an
escalatory spiral with the Iranians that
could lead to war right I mean this was
an attack by Iranian proxies on the US
which resulted in the death of American
we responded to that not in the smartest
way but we responded to that if the
Iranians the Iranians are going to
continue to do this they're gonna
continue to put pressure on us and if we
respond in a way that starts a a spiral
we could lead to what tweets are pretty
concerning the president says that
Iran's gonna be held responsible calls
it a threat and then Iran's supreme
leader says basically I dare you you
know you can't do anything so at the end
of the day the Iranians wanted us to
respond the way we did they wanted us to
attack those targets in Iraq because
they knew what their response would be
which be which which would be an Iraqi
protest against the embassy and the
Iraqi government allowing it to happen
the mistake we made here
was doing the follow-up attacks in Iraq
rather than just in Syria so our
adversaries does it appear that
President Trump is vulnerable right now
when you look at him facing impeachment
and an election I think the Iranians are
going to continue putting this pressure
on us no matter what right no matter
impeachment no matter election I think
interestingly the Iranians and the North
Koreans want two different things here
right the Iranians want a Democrat in
the White House in 2021
the North Koreans want President Trump
there it's very interesting difference
quickly Michael what is the u.s. do at
this point what's the smartest thing we
can do to defuse this the smartest thing
we can do is get secretary Pompeo to
Baghdad to sit down with the Iraqi
government and essentially apologize for
conducting attacks in Iraq without their
permission and try to make sure that
that vote in the Iraqi parliament either
doesn't happen or comes out the right
way and if I read you correctly the
Democrats might be favored by Iran
because a Democrat might reenter that
nuclear agreement exactly all right
Michael thank you very much I appreciate
it
you